You've been hearing a lot about him
because he has been rising in the polls.
And Vivek Ramasamy
also recently suggested that he wouldn't
have certified
the election results in the way
that former Vice President Mike Pence did
Here's what I would have said.
We need single day
voting on Election Day.
We need paper ballots
and we need government issued ID
matching the voter file.
And if we achieve that,
then we have achieved victory.
And we should not have
any further complain
about election integrity in my capacity
as president of the Senate.
I would have led through
that level of reform
then on that condition, certify
the election results,
served it
up to the president, President Trump,
then to sign that into law
and on January 7th,
declare to the reelection campaign
pursuant to a free and fair election.
I think that was a missed opportunity
for those familiar with
Schoolhouse Rock and separation
of powers.
The vice president has neither
the authority to send legislation
directly to Congress,
nor does he have the authority
to just simply deny election results.
But it is notable that since 2022
and 2022 Vivek Ramaswamy
seems to disagree
with 2023 Vivek Ramaswamy.
In his book
just last year
he mocked Trump's election lies.
He called his arguments weak
and he said that reasonable Republicans
don't believe that the election
was stolen.
And on the question of the vice
president specifically,
he wrote, quote,
Mike Pence,
the man
I have great respect for, decided
it was his constitutional duty
to resist the president's attempts
to get him to unilaterally overturn
the results of the election.
He goes on to write,
Our institutions did hold in the end,
but they shouldn't have been tested Now,
meantime,
that's not the only thing that Ramaswamy
is getting attention for.
He also has gotten
quite a bit of backlash
after calling a black
Democratic congresswoman
a modern grand wizard of the modern KKK.
At a stop in Iowa on Friday,
Ayanna Pressley, she's
in the Congress today.
She's a member of the squad.
Her words, not mine.
We don't want any more black faces
that don't want to be a black voice.
We don't want any more brown faces
that don't want to be a brown voice.
Literally word for word.
I'm not putting any dirty words
in anybody's mouth.
Abraham Kennedy
wrote the book How to Be an Anti-Racist.
I wrote Woking.
It was a pretty successful
book, has sold more copies than mine.
Here's what it says.
Opening lines.
The remedy to past discrimination
is present discrimination.
The remedy to present
discrimination is future discrimination.
So there there's little gaslight
you when you say this stuff is like,
oh, you're just making that
critical race theory. Step up, Neera.
These aren't my words.
These are the words of
the modern grand wizards
of the modern KKK.
The man he's talking about there, Ibram
X Kendi, joins me now.
He's the author of, as Mr.
Ramasamy was saying,
How to Be an Anti-Racist.
And he's also the director
of the Center
for Anti-Racist Research
at Boston University.
Thanks for being here.
I want to get just your reaction
to what you heard him saying there.
Compare you and Congresswoman Pressley
to the modern grand wizards of the KKK.
I just think it's incredibly dangerous.
The Ku Klux Klan is is the oldest
and quite possibly most violent
white terrorist group,
really a terrorist, domestic
terrorist group in American history.
They have engaged
in generations
of violence
against against black people,
against Jews,
against all sorts of groups.
Stadium agree with.
And they've also
expressed ideas of of racial hierarchy
and white supremacy ideas
that are that
I and Congresswoman
Pressley have repeatedly
and constantly challenge.
So it's incredibly dangerous,
especially in this moment
where, you know,
all sorts of reports
point to white supremacists
as the greatest domestic
terrorist threat of our time
to be comparing people to them
that have spent their lives
challenging them
and actually who the Klan hates
because the Klan really doesn't like me.
Look, yesterday
on CNN's State of the Union, I ran
a somebody was pressed about this
and pressed about the violence of the KKK
and how that could possibly compare
to anything
that you or Congresswoman
Pressley have said.
But he said that
he wanted to provoke a, quote,
honest discussion in this country.
So just help us here.
I mean,
what would an honest discussion
on race
in this country in this moment
actually look like?
Well, I think we would start
with racial disparities and inequities.
We would identify the evidence
that points to, for instance,
let's say
black
people are more likely
to be impoverished or incarcerated
or killed by police
or dying of heart disease and cancer.
And we would also recognize that there's
nothing inferior
about black people as a group.
So there must
be policies and practices
that are leading to those disparities.
And as American
as we should come together
to identify
and eliminate
those disparities,
that's an honest conversation
based on evidence
and based on notions of racial equality.
There's a difference of opinion,
I think, here
between you and Ramos for me about
whether it requires actively
addressing racial wrongs in
order to to address them in the future.
But that kind of rhetoric from him
doesn't seem to be
part of that conversation.
I do wonder, though,
I mean, this is happening on the campaign
trail, right?
He's one of several candidates of color
in the Republican race,
but he's doing really well
and is making these arguments
at a particular moment
for him in this race.
Why do you.
Do you think that this is a part
of why he is doing so well right now?
Without question.
And unfortunately, you have
too many candidates,
particularly Republican candidates
of color
who recognize that one of the ways
in which
they can sort of boost
their political appeal to right.
Republicans is by telling them
that they are not racist
and then turning around
and attacking those who are pointing out
racism as the real problem,
as the real racist.
And you know, we've seen candidate
after candidate be boosted,
particularly candidates of color,
by by essentially feeding
white Republicans their denial.
And that's all Vivek is doing.
He knows that.
And the irony is that is based on racism
and it's based on his skin color.
At the same time,
he's claiming racism is
no longer an issue.
Ever.
Max Kennedy, thank you
for joining us tonight
and responding directly to all of that.
Thank you for having me.